الينا من موسكو الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الرزيلي فاتيكاروف سيد
فازيلي الخلاف بين فاجنر وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه معلن ومنذ فتره لهذه الدرجه موسكو
غير قادره على السيطره على هذه المجموعات
العسكريه غير النظاميه
ما كنت
لاقول
واتحدث عن شركه عسكريه خاصه معينه لانه في
اي دوله
وروسيا هي احد هذه الدول من غير مسموح به
ان يكون هناك اشخاص مسلحين دون ان ينزلوا
تحت مظله المؤسسات الحكوميه لذلك كل
المتطوعين الذين يحاربون للطرف الروسي يجب
ان يوقعوا عقودا رسميا اما مع الحرس
الوطني او مع المخابرات او مع حكومه او او
عفوا مع وزاره الدفاع لذلك اي قوات عسكريه
مسلحه دون عقود هم المتطوعين فقط وممكن ان
يشاركوا بالعمليات او الجنود الذين يتم
تعبئتهم
او الجنود المتعاقدين لذلك اي
يريد ان يحارب ويشترك في المعارك يجب ان
يوقع عقود مع الجهات الرسميه وخاصه وزاره
الدفاع انت كيف تقرا هذا الخلاف
ودوافع بريكوجين بتعامل
هذه النبره التي يتحدث بها ازاء وزاره
الدفاع
انا اعتقد
انه في اي دوله قانونيه
لا يسمح
باي تسليح غير قانوني يجب ان يكون التسليح
على اساس القانون ونحن متوجهين لهذا الفهم
من جانب اخر اريد ان اقول ان جميع
المتطوعين الذين يحاربون جيدا ونحن نحارب
كتفا الى كتف ونصل للاهداف الموضوعه لكن
شركه فاجنر تعمل منذ فتره وبمباركه النظام
الروسي وحققت الكثير من الانتصارات مثل ما
تقول روسيا
نعم هذا سليم ان شركه فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه هم ابطال وصلوا لنجاحات عاليه جدا
ولا احد ينكر هذا ولكن من جانب اخر يجب ان
نفهم انه يجب ان يكون كل شيء مبني على
القانون لذلك اي شخص مسلح في الجبهات اما
ان يكون قد وقع عقدا رسميا او انه جندي تم
تعبئه اثناء التعبئه العسكريه الجزئيه اي
شيء اخر لا يسمح به روسيا التي تتفاخر بان
جيشها من اكبر الجيوش في العالم لماذا
تعتمد على هذه المجموعات غير النظاميه
التي تسميهم بالمتطوعين
روسيا تعتمد على قواتها المسلحه ولكن اذا
كان هناك متطوعين يريدوا دعم القوات
العسكريه نحن لا نعرض هذا ونحارب معا
ونحارب دفاعا عن ارضنا ودولتنا ضد الناتو
التي ان تريد الانضمام لها مواقع روسيه
سابقه وهي اوكرانيا ونعلم ان هذا غير
قانوني لذلك نحن نوحد جميع القوى والقدرات
لهدف واحد الخبية العسكري والاستراتيجي
روف من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك